Peggy 18
my name is mechanics e-coat a creative
director of Assassin's Creed syndicate
and here is your first look at our game
it's reckless it's clever
the blight has control every criminal
enterprise in the city if they work for
us
yes but they work for the Templars they
paid off by the Templars slight
difference if we take control of the
gangs retake control of London from the
bottom up you are talking about building
yourself an army with fried LMS is
complete madness you need to consolidate
your control I can keep the rival gangs
and the police from sweeping in and
seizing the territory can't very well
send bloody Nora an engraved invitation
we have no idea where they're holed up
yeah we do
you found them the glass is rock
breaking out who agree bloody Nora will
be there
good work Clara tremendous work Jacob
can't talk now Henry duty calls
to your health apologies mr. Breen
we are now in the city of London one of
the seven boroughs that you'll
experience in Assassin's Creed syndicate
the city of London was the economic and
financial heart of London in the 19th
century the borough fully embodies the
AUSA land bustle spirit associated with
Victorian London booming businesses busy
sidewalks and even busier streets new to
our game our iconic modes of
transportation including trains and
carriages only present in Victorian
London carriages will change how you
play Assassin's Creed you can take the
reins and traverse the city faster than
ever before you can also hide in them
adding another tool to your stealth game
or run over targets and enemies the
possibilities are endless in this
mission Jacob wants to take over one of
the Templars control gangs in order to
build an army against the Templars that
run the city to do so he will need to
conquer the borough by dislodging the
enemy gang from their stronghold
not unlike big cities today rich and
poor share the same environment even the
richest neighborhood like Westminster
had areas where the police would not
dare set foot these slums were where
street gangs ruled with the simple push
of a button will activate stealth mode
as we are entering enemy controlled
territory also new to our game the Rope
launcher will change the way you
navigate throughout the city with this
new tool you can climb the Aya's
building in seconds or a zipline from
rooftop to rooftop
let's trigger eco vision to study our
surroundings
we can see that one of our allies is in
trouble let's give him a hand we first
need to eliminate the lookout to make
sure he doesn't call reinforcements the
throwing knives will take him out
silently
[Music]
we are facing a lot of enemies so the
ads first approach is probably not a
good idea
also new to our game is the ability to
use the environment to take out your
enemies
another one of our allies is in trouble
let's take care of this before it's too
late for him
[Music]
now that our ally is free from the OPA
we'll ask him to assist us in our fight
for this slum here is the stronghold
leader highlighted in yellow let's try
to take him out with stealth as he is
more dangerous than common thugs and
we'll use the illusio genic darts to
turn our enemies against one another
[Music]
[Music]
this slum is now one and your gang
occupies the territory boys deal with
this we were caught in a trap
orchestrated by bloody North one of the
seventh Empire gang leaders a rule of
the borough has been one of cruelty and
suffering we need to dig her out once
and for all
let's go
bloody Norris thugs are trying to make
sure you don't get them over ramming our
carriage to kill our carriage has taken
some damage but seems to be holding up
[Applause]
[Music]
we made it to the gangway an all-out
confrontation between your gang and your
rival for the ultimate control of the
borough Jacob feels right at home in
these fights
thanks to our new fighting system as it
is faster and more responsive than ever
before
ladies and gentlemen we are jacob and
evie frye
and as of this moment you all work for
us
[Music]
[Applause]
you